[Music]
hillary duff is showing off her old
dance moves and proving she still got it
you're so kind after past performances
of the actress recently went viral on
tick-tock hillary decided to join in on
the fun recreating the dance moves to
her song with love seen during this 2007
appearance on the tonight show with jay
leno
yep that's hillary on the left duetting
creator young daddy cack who recreated
the choreo in a video last month be
prepared to be impressed
[Music]
the younger star addressed why she
decided to film the video in her caption
hilariously explaining so i can stop
receiving texts about this it just feels
very surreal
but this isn't the first time hillary
fully embraced her beloved past
last month she reacted to joe jonas and
sophie turner dressing up on halloween
as the lizzie mcguire movie characters
paulo and isabella
sing to me paulo
[Music]
sophie instagramed this picture with her
husband dressed up as the singing
partners while sophie's staircase
co-star olivia de jong channeled her
inner lizzy hillary commented i'm
screaming with three crying faces
[Music]
and it seems the former disney star
loves duetting tick tockers when they
recreate her past roles
like in this video
[Music]
and here's how hillary reacted when
another fan showed love for her single
come clean
hillary
[Music]
when the actress isn't busy making us
super nostalgic she's been hard at work
on her new hulu show how i met your
father when hillary caught up with e.t
at the 10th annual baby to baby gala she
couldn't help but gush about sex and the
city alum kim cattrall joining the
sitcom as the older version of her
character i have to tell you i'm in
i've been to work every single day for
the past like 11 weeks and the day that
she shot was my day off and i was like
i'm coming to work like what the hell
don't leave me out of this one because
we're not actually shooting together
this year she plays all the
the flash forwards and she's just
incredible like really incredible she
speaks and you're just like i'm
listening you know she's just a force
but she's so kind and she's so warm and
um so excited to have her on board truly
it's a it's a really cool show and i'm
like really proud of it and happy to
have someone like her stepping on it
you